Is there any good news in the polls for
Donald Trump at the six-month mark of
his presidency? The simple answer is: not
much. He is less popular than any other
president of this point in his tenure in
terms of his overall approval rating.
President Obama's approval rating in the
summer his first year in office was
around 60 percent. Trump's approval rating
hovers around 40 percent. President Trump gets
negative marks on handling foreign
policy and health care. People are split
about his handling of the economy. The
president still has the support of most
Republicans; slightly more than 80% of
them approve of the job that he's doing.
But large majorities of independents and
Democrats disapproved. Democrats
especially disapprove intensely. But
there is one bright spot in an otherwise
dismal poll landscape for the
president: Although Americans give Barack
Obama more credit than Trump for the
economy's resilience, President Trump
gets generally positive marks on job
creation and keeping jobs at home, both
of which are high priorities for most
Americans. How do you think President
How do you think President Trump is doing? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.